the latest issue of las vegas weekly is
all about love
pandemic dating tips romantic outings
even some helpful advice for those
looking to connect
online staff writer cindy moonread
joining us once again cindy you say this
topic is of special interest to you
please share that's right because i
am a single and on the prowl i guess
looking for that pandemic date
cindy we love your candor all right so
dating's got to be quite challenging
right now how can folks make sure that
they're doing this process safely um the
first thing to do is
pre-screen your dates so you want to
make sure this is somebody you
you want to meet um and so before you
just randomly go to meet a stranger at a
bar
have a phone call or a video chat with
them and
discuss your pandemic safety habits to
make sure that you're on the same page
certainly that's very smart you outlined
some great
socially distanced dating spots for all
relationship stages so please highlight
some of those faves for us
so i think if you're on a first date the
best choice is to go to a place with a
patio that's in public it's safe you can
enjoy a drink or a coffee or a bite to
eat
but you're not indoors where the germs
are kind of
mingling and so some of my favorite
places are in downtown las vegas so
atomic kitchen has a huge outdoor patio
there's a great in the arts district
there's a great patio shared by
garage yeast and some other bars
downtown
rebar has one tenea creek brewery
closer to north las vegas big dogs
brewery the weather is perfect right now
anyways
so it's always a great way for a first
date ah
very good call there are so many places
all right the second date maybe
exploring the outdoors yeah so i think
that for pandemic safety one of the
choices
is to again look for outdoor things and
and the great thing about vegas is
there's no there's no lack of outdoor
options
so you can go have a picnic at sunset
park
you could go explore valley of fire
state park
you could um you could go to ferguson's
downtown and explore the shops so
there's you know no matter your interest
there's a lot of outdoor options for a
fun second date that's still
low stress yeah and what about third
date and beyond huh you could increase
those hours outside right
yeah so now you know you actually like
the person so you can
do something with them like say you can
go skiing at lee canyon they have lots
of social distancing options
you could go explore boulder city
there's a disc golf courses you could
play
go kayaking together on the river or
just stay home and netflix and chill
together because what's the point of the
relationship if you don't get to stay
home
well cindy you've been great as always
you look beautiful
happy early valentine and we wish you
good luck with your dating
activities and thank you so much for
this awesome advice
of course there's so much more that she
has to share in this week's issue
including online dating tips from a
dating coach even dating stories from
locals
make sure to pick up a copy